[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and in this video we're
going to be breaking down that big cameo
in the Mandalorian season 3 episode 4.
it was a major moment of redemption and
in case you don't know why it meant so
much then this is the video for you to
add it we're gonna be breaking it all
down and going over who this is the
history that this actor has had with
Star Wars and also why this scene here
means more than just him saving grogu
now this kind of almost been this retcon
in real life and I actually see a lot of
people these days saying the prequel
trilogy wasn't hated upon when it was
first released I'm guessing this must
prove the Multiverse exists because I
remember it being completely ripped
apart by almost the entire fan base and
critics at the time although Yoon
McGregor and Natalie Portman and Liam
Neeson all went on to have major careers
there were some casualties that came off
the back of the bad reception of the
first film the first was Jake Lloyd
who's been very open about how much
playing Anakin destroyed his life the
second was armored best who was behind
the role of Jar Jar Binks seen as a
wacky and over the top kids character
the first film relied heavily on him and
a lot of the criticism levied towards
the movie focused on how much people
said that he ruined scenes just Google
georgear Rune Star Wars and you're gonna
be hit with hundreds of Articles talking
about how the character destroyed the
franchise and set the prequel trilogy
off on the worst but possible he was a
comedic character that took away from
the serious political tone that was
laced throughout the movie and best
troll was minimized in the sequels due
to how much backlash there was now
tragically if you type the guy's name in
on YouTube one of the first things that
comes up is a video about how the actor
almost ended his own life in it he
recounts what happened with him before
and after the role and it's very
heartbreaking to watch this past summer
I wanted to take my nine-year-old son
with me to New York City I really wanted
to take him back to where I grew up
and I wanted to spend a significant
amount of time there so he could really
get to know the city that I
love in the city that I came up in and
the city that kind of made me we stayed
in Brooklyn and I lived in Brooklyn
for a lot of years and there were
certain things that I did coming up that
would inspire me
and one of those things was to walk
across the Brooklyn Bridge I would walk
across the bridge and I would see the
city and I would see the towers when
they were there and
I would look at that and say oh human
beings did this and it would make me
want to keep going and keep moving
so I wanted to walk across the bridge
with my son then I got to this point
on the bridge
that I hadn't seen in a long time and it
was really the reason why I hadn't
walked across the bridge in in 18 years
it was the spot where I almost ended my
life
I grabbed my son and my phone and I took
a picture of that moment
the reason why I almost ended my life on
the Brooklyn Bridge was because 20 years
ago I played Jar Jar Binks in Star Wars
I faced a media backlash that really
made me feel like my life was over now I
know that when most people criticize
something on the Internet that they're
not actually doing it to attack the
people behind it when you say how crap
of a character someone is you're often
not going after the actor directly
unless you tag them in it which is weird
I know myself that sometimes I'll say
bad stuff in a review and it genuinely
never crosses my mind that people behind
it are actually going to watch it and
then take it to heart however actors
often do and even if they manage to miss
99.9 of the comments said about them
they'll still be the ones that managed
to slip through now it's clear that the
negative criticism eventually made its
way to arm at best and this proved to be
almost too much for the actor to deal
with yeah was an unknown that was given
a big break as one of the leads in what
was probably the largest movie franchise
of all time when you look back at the
naughties he was also taking part in a
pioneering motion capture performance
and you can imagine if it happened to
you then you'd go into it thinking this
was the best moment of your life I never
thought it was a possibility to be in
that movie
and I was doing a show called stop in
New York and
I got lucky the casting director for
Star Wars was in the audience of one of
the shows and she asked me to audition
and I got it and it was one of those
magical things it was one of those
special things that happens that you
don't really hear about next thing I
knew I was at industrial lights and
magic and and
George Lucas was directing me
for screen tests
I loved the work and throughout my life
I've always wanted to be one of those
actors that disappeared into roles jar
jar was that times a hundred because I
could literally disappear into jar jar I
could I was not there
and that to me was the height of of
the art form the thing that makes jar
jar special from a lot of the other CTI
characters that have happened since ilm
was writing the code for this
as I was doing things so the code that's
being used now for CGI
I was a part of creating that
and on set everybody was like oh this is
going to be great this is amazing and
get ready to be a star and all that and
I believed it you know as a 24 year old
young actor looking at your career and
looking at your future the best thing to
feel is all right here we go this is
going to open the doors to
so many different things and so many
different opportunities
I've seen the backlash to it it's
probably Gonna Make You plummet lower
than you've ever been before and I don't
think it's an over exaggeration to say
that this role ruined arm its life Ahmed
open sub about his depression in the
video and he goes otherwise all of the
backlash you received made him
contemplate ending at all however he
explains that when he went to do it on
the bridge that a gust of wind came when
he was standing on a steel girder that
could have sent him over the edge he
caught himself and in that moment he
realized that if he was really gonna do
it then he would have let it carry him
away he climbed back onto the walkway
back from the edge this was done both
literally and spiritually now why are we
making this depressing video that that's
dealing with some pretty heavy subject
matter I think it's because ahmed's a
great example of how things can always
get better and that there's always a way
back even when it seems like you're at
your lowest point in our breakdown of
the episode I talked about her seeing
him made me tear up a bit I went beyond
just seeing an actor I knew playing a
Star Wars character at this point I was
well aware of what what Ahmed had been
through and the fact that the actor had
returned to Star Wars and was now in a
Big Moment Like This carried such an
emotional punch to it but yes we've all
sat and theorized about who could have
been the Jedi that saved groku and this
is range from things like Mace Windu to
yaddle and even the inquisitors like
Seven Sisters there were even some
theories that George R saved grogu which
in the end I guess he kinda did now I
genuinely think that having best come
back tops them all and it gives him an
important Moment In The Saga that feels
like something fans can celebrate
instead of just criticizing I think that
most people feel bad for what Ahmed went
through and hearing his story about his
mental health struggles really pulls out
your heartstrings however what he does
is that he exemplifies that there is
hope even in darkness and that he can
come back from things no matter how big
they seem I think Hub is also summing
thematically that's at the heart of all
Star Wars projects and it being carried
across its way to enact their cements
why Star Wars infiltrated so much of our
Lives it's more than just a friend
franchise it's things we become attached
to and moments like this extend beyond
what's on the page and Screen Now best
hand play color run back before and he
first appeared as him in the Jedi Temple
game show there's a little kids thing
that no one really thought would go
anywhere but for his character to be
brought up into the Saga like this
really felt like a home run not only for
the actor but also for his character
having him protecting a child and
getting this amazing action scene it
does feel like best can at least have
some good will out of the franchise and
perhaps now he'll look back on it as
being the thing that made him rather
than being what destroyed him I want to
put words in the guy's mouth but I think
this scene is such an important thing to
talk about as it has so many layers to
it had things ended on the bridge then
best never would have had his child and
he never would have seen the 180 that
the fans have had it over him I know
it's cliche to say but there is light at
the end of the tunnel and and it's
important to bear in mind that every
person has this weird little thing built
into them what I'm talking about is that
we all have this thing where if some
things going bad even if just for a
little bit now we instantly change our
minds stay and think that that's the new
normal our perception of these moments
can make us think it'll stay that way
forever but it's never the case and once
you're on the other side of it you look
back and realize that your perception
was wrong however it's difficult to see
the fog when you're out in the middle of
it once you've made it through it makes
all the difference twenty years later
I'm on the bridge with my son
and I'm looking at the spot
[Music]
just looking at it
I'm gonna take this picture
I don't know what to do with this
picture so I just look at it you know I
don't know what to do with it
[Music]
and I was really afraid to share this
picture you know I was really scared
because you put on this armor every day
and you make it look like things don't
affect you
can't
hide this anymore this happened to me
yeah I felt this way
took the picture of me and my boy and I
put it on Twitter
all of a sudden it went everywhere
people were calling me and
everybody started talking about it and
it was surprising because I never really
uh I never really thought anybody would
care
we talk a lot about things going viral
and usually when things go viral
it's something negative
[Music]
I didn't feel like what I posted went
viral I felt like it went communal and I
felt like it went communal because
of the support
I got
that I never thought was there
and I'm glad I shared this moment
because the response that I got that
were from people that shared a similar
moment
we're all here we're all here now
we made it through the next day
because I shared that between me and my
son
[Music]
I can get through 20 more years of next
days
and that ends the video I know it can be
depressing to talk about this stuff but
I think it's also sublifting to know
that no matter what you're going through
that someone's went through something
similar and that they came back from it
everyone has the capability of having a
good life after and I think that's why
this scene is so important we all know
what our my best went through but this
acts very much as a Redemption and just
in the same way that Andrew Garfield got
to come back as Spider-Man and stuff
like that these returns they have a
deeper layer to them now I hope you've
enjoyed this video hopefully it's
uplifted you a bit you know we've been
through some emotional things and if
it's touched you on that kind of level
then make sure you leave your thoughts
below it might be really important as
someone who's out there reading them and
it could make a world of difference in
someone else's life by the way thank you
for sticking through the video hopefully
I'll see you on another one soon and
yeah thanks for sitting through this
more contemplative look in the end I've
been Paul you've been the best and I
hope you enjoy the rest of your week you
take care peace